cabe Early Show what's your biggest
issue problem as foreign secretary well
I think the biggest challenge we have at
the moment is that the international
order is changing and we have this
system that really Britain helped create
under Churchill's leadership after 45
where we've had peace prosperity growth
in democracy across the world and now
that all feels like it's being
challenged in a pretty serious way and
there are lots of things that really
worry us the behavior of Russia is
perhaps top of the list at the moment
after what happened at Salisbury but if
you look at the Middle East there are
some really worrying things and Britain
has a very very important role we are
one of the permanent members of the
Security Council we have a special
responsibility and sometimes at home we
don't appreciate just how respected the
British voice is but obviously in the
context of brexit is very important for
us to make people understand that
Britain is out there we're fighting for
our national interest for our citizens
like nazarine but also we want to make
sure that the world stays peaceful
stable and the things that have led to
so many advances for Humanity are
protected okay lots to get our teeth in
there let's start with Russia then
should we've seen as you listed it at
top of your agenda how did your meeting
with Sergey Lavrov go the Foreign
Minister well I think the diplomatic
phrase we use as a frank exchange of
views it was it was pretty tough because
it is not acceptable for Russia to
instruct two GRU agents to use chemical
weapons on British soil the first time
it's ever happened this is a very
significant thing and the significance
isn't just about a bilateral spat
between Russia and the UK we have
international norms where you don't use
chemical weapons these are after nuclear
weapons these are the most horrible
weapons that you can use and recently
those norms have been changing we've
seen Assad using them in
and and now the Russians using them on
the streets of Britain and it would be a
terrible step back for the world if we
went to a situation where using these
horrible horrible weapons just became
normal and we don't want that to happen
not for Britain's say not for the
world's sake and that's why our message
to Russia is very straightforward if you
do this the price will be too high but
they did it they did it and I think one
of the reasons that they did it
incidentally is that the last time this
happened back in 2005 with the
Litvinenko poisoning they feel they got
away with it and that's why Teresa Mae's
reaction this time has been very
different and I am sure that in the
inner recesses of the Kremlin if they're
reflecting on whether that was a smart
thing to do they must be wondering
because they can't have been expecting
to resume to put together a coalition
that saw 153 Russian spies expelled from
capitals in 28 countries across the
world so they paid a very high
diplomatic price but they need to
understand that it will not be a
comfortable place for Russia in the
world if this is the way they behaved
what did you say to level I said to him
that countries like Russia and Britain
need to be standing together to make the
world a peaceful place and if one of us
is sending army officers onto the
streets of the other and using chemical
weapons that's not going to happen and
that is the wrong thing to do so it
could affect the peace between our two
countries well it clearly affects the
relations between our two countries now
I don't think there's any possibility of
war or anything like that
but Russia has a lot of influence across
the world and we want them to be a force
for good in the world as is Britain and
the one thing now that is really at
stake the thing that people like Assad
other dictators around the world are
wondering is
is it now okay to use chemical weapons
and Britain is saying no and Britain is
leading the international coalition that
is saying anyone who goes down this
route will find the prices too high
to what extent do what our security
services have to accept some
responsibility for what happened given
that these two men we knew that well at
least one of them was a giu agent he was
honoured decorated by Putin himself and
yet they got visas well you know these
were you know we think there were
aliases and so they applied for visas
and it's very difficult in a situation
like that to weed people out but let's
be clear we don't stop Russian military
coming to the UK they don't stop our
military going to Russia what is then
important is what they do when they
arrive and of course when something like
this happens it is very very serious to
what extent do you think the at least
one death and several people and taken
seriously including a police officer
leads to the desk of the president well
we all think that it's unlikely that a
great deal happens in Russia without the
the nod coming from the highest levels
we are being very careful about what we
say because we want to be sure that
everything we say is properly backed
with evidence but what I would say to
President Putin is that in the end it is
his choice as to whether Russia is on
the wrong side of international opinion
or the right side and if they become the
major country the only major country on
the Security Council that is giving the
nod to the use of chemical weapons then
that puts Russia in a very different
place and if his great dream is for
Russia to be shown respect by the
international community this is the
wrong way to do it you talk about our
diplomats being expelled right around
the world we saw as a response to that
or President Putin did he basically said
he paraded these two guys on the tip on
attorney
he said that they were tourists and
there was absolutely nothing to worry
about didn't know what we were talking
about the way to impact on Russia and on
President Putin some might say is
through financial sanctions you do have
the ability to do that but up until now
under the wealth orders that were
brought in in 2017 nothing's been done
well we that's I think I'm fair I mean
that we have to follow due process in
this country that is one of the things
that we're proud of and there is a
police process and there is a large
number of investigations going in place
so that we can actually implement these
unexplained wealth orders and I think
it's really important to say that you
know thanks to the extraordinary work of
people like Bill Browder and the make
this Magnitsky act that has happened
both here and also in the UK we are
finding ways of putting economic
pressure on Russia because one thing
that is very clear is that some of these
people at the top of the Russian regime
have accumulated huge amounts of wealth
outside Russia which they want to
protect and and we should not be
complicit in that if they are breaching
these very important international norms
so they need to be worried you're coming
for them as far as money is concerned
they need to understand that if they
continue to behave this way the price
will always be too high can we talk
about around nothing so Gary Ratliff you
spoke to the Iranian counterparts here
as well things looked as though they
were going to be that we were going in
the right direction we waited about the
furlough that she was out for 72 hours
and we expected he'd be coming back to
the United Kingdom very quickly what
went wrong well I am I have a four year
old thought of myself and and maybe
that's why I feel so strongly for the
agony that both Richard and Nazanin are
going through
and the truth is that Iran has made a
decision to detain innocent people and
it's very important to say it's not just
Nazanin we only talk about names when
the families are willing to talk about
names and there are other families who
are suffering as much as Richard
Radcliffe is but they don't want those
names talked about but they are
detaining innocent people as a an
instrument of diplomatic leverage and we
can't do that and we can't accept it and
we've just been talking about Russia but
even Russia doesn't do this you know
Brits who go to Russia on the whole
don't have to worry about the kind of
things that Nazanin is is going so I had
a very very frank discussion with the
Iranian Foreign Minister I went through
this the Iranian regime is very
complicated I think probably the Foreign
Affairs Ministry of the the people who
most want to solve this issue but I made
it very clear that our policy to Iran is
not settled and there will be
consequences if they continue to think
that this is a tool of diplomacy it
should not be it did look as though as I
said that she was on her way home she
isn't we don't know what went wrong one
thing that might have gone wrong was
that British Airways canceled its direct
flights to Tehran on the very same day
that she was released the Iranians lost
face as a result could that I've had
anything to do with it well British
Airways have to take their decisions as
an independent commercial entity we
don't have any influence over that but
my point really is is exactly this that
whether Nazneen whether Nazarene is
imprisoned or not has got absolutely
nothing to do with trade relations with
Iran whether airlines are flying between
London and Tehran and it is unacceptable
for the Iranian regime to punish
innocent people because of commercial
decisions trade decisions diplomatic
decisions that they don't like this is
not the way that countries interact with
each other in the modern world and Iran
needs to understand
that we will not let it rest you know
Nazanin and her husband Richard they are
incredibly brave people you've been
talking to to Richard amazingly brave in
impossible circumstances they are the
flag carrier for the United Kingdom and
we know that the authorities did not
want to lose face in Iran and they lost
face in Iran when buddy show is
cancelled their flights should they at
least not have checked with you first
before they they carried out that
decision well we stand they don't check
with us where we are we were always
aware that this was a possibility but we
didn't know that this was their decision
until they took their decision but you
know there is absolutely no link at all
which you know that was at least
unfortunate let me put it another way
okay there are a hundred and ninety
three nations in the United Nations
where we are now in New York and all of
them have frictions and tensions but
it's only Iran that decides when it
doesn't like something that another
country does that it's going to lock up
an innocent person who just happens to
be visiting Tehran and that is not
acceptable it has to stop and we won't
let it rest we've got a lot to go
through and I know that your time is
very limited so let me ask you about
Saudi Arabia if I may you said that we
need to share the same values as our
allies what values do we share with
Saudi Arabia well we have a strategic
partnership with Saudi Arabia we both
work very closely together on
counterterrorism there are other things
is there are there foreign secretary I
mean and that's self-interest
intelligence is a commodity isn't it
it's not value I think it's both but I
would say that there are things that we
don't agree with Saudi Arabia Iran there
are things to do with the treatment of
women for example in Saudi Arabia where
they're making good progress that things
are going in the right direction women
are driving for the first time but we'd
like them to go a lot further but I
think the truth is that we have big
concerns about the way the war is being
prosecuted in Yemen and we use the fact
that we're a partner of Saudi Arabia's
to exert as much influence as we
can to try and get a solution because we
are the Security Council member at the
United Nations responsible for Yemen we
have a special responsibility to try and
see things progress away from the
humanitarian tragedy that we have at the
moment but you talked about red lines
and we have to accept our level of
responsibility for this humanitarian
disaster that's happening at the moment
in the Yemen Saudi Arabia supported by
us accused by the UN of war crimes
thousands of civilian deaths at school
boss we saw a school bus was obliterated
absolutely disgusting behavior
surely that is a red line for us it is
totally unacceptable and incidentally it
wasn't just that instant there's been a
range of incidents saying there are
three separate incidents in August that
happened and I spoke to the Saudi
Arabian pharmacist in the strongest
possible terms I'm seeing him actually
later today in New York this is totally
unacceptable
Saudi Arabia actually said they broke
their own rules of engagement they're
having an investigation they will hold
the individuals responsible to account
but the big question with Yemen is
whether the Saudis and the Emiratis who
were also involved in this conflict
understand that this is not going to be
solved with a military solution there
has to be a political process and
Britain with our influence as a as a
partner of Saudi Arabia in the region we
are saying to them there has to be a
political process and that's the message
I'll be giving today okay so that that's
is a red line for us what's happening in
Yemen what about you talked about women
in Saudi Arabia let me I'm sure you're
aware of the female political activists
but for the benefit of our viewers
Israel Gangamma she is shared rule to be
beheaded her crime was to take part in a
peaceful anti-government protest what
are we doing what are you doing to try
to stop that execution well we feel very
strongly when things like that happen
when I think let's be clear human rights
abuses wherever they happen whether it's
Saudi Arabia whether it's Burma whether
it's Yemen
they are something that Britain feels
very strongly about we are one of the
countries in the world that has set up
the international order and we want to
make it a taboo for these things to
happen and with different countries we
behave in different ways now with
countries like Saudi Arabia countries
like China the way you make the most
progress is by talking to them in
private if you talk about these things
publicly you lose the access they say we
don't want to deal with you and you put
yourself in a position where you have no
influence over what's happening so when
I go to Saudi Arabia when I go to China
when I go to countries like that I
raised these issues I fly the flag for
British values but I don't think they're
just British values I think they're
universal values and I think it's very
important people in those countries know
what we stand for okay but you know we
are arms sales to Saudi four point six
billion pounds that's the reason that we
continue to have a relationship with
Saudi Arabia isn't it no we have a
commercial relationship with Saudi
Arabia we have a strategic relationship
there are bombs that have not gone off
in the streets of Britain because of the
counterintelligence work that we've done
with Saudi Arabia and we're working with
them to try and create peace in the
region but the truth is that we also
want to make sure that all countries
everywhere behave in a humane and
civilized way and we do everything that
we can to try and influence countries
like Saudi President Trump do you
appreciate his values the person Trump
is someone who makes very strong
statements on social media I think it's
fair to say that he's be more active on
social media than
any other president we agree with some
of them we don't agree with others when
I was health secretary I went into
battle with him on Twitter when he
criticized the NHS so I don't pretend
that we agree with him on everything but
I think you have to look at what he does
as much as what he says and the truth is
that America is our closest ally in the
world they support the international
order that we built together with
America and when it comes to issues like
Russia that we talked about earlier
America expelled as many diplomats as
the whole of the EU put together so they
are with us and I think that
relationship is incredibly important
yeah let me pick you up on that if I may
please France actually when the u.s.
expelled those Russian diplomats in
solidarity with us over the Solsbury
poisoning the Washington Post says that
the president was furious felt misled
and a lot of curse words were used that
strikes most people in this country and
in the United Kingdom as plausible so it
does look as though we didn't
necessarily have the support from the
president that we were expecting it and
it's the people that work with him and
for him that are that you have to do
business with well it would surprise me
at all if they have the same fierce and
vigorous internal debates about issues
as we have in the UK but in the end the
decision was taken by the President to
expel those Russian spies in solidarity
with the UK because he recognized that
like us we have to defend the
international order and I think with
President Trump you know we have to be
careful not to get drawn into some of
the domestic political issues and the
British Foreign Secretary but we have to
recognize in international affairs there
is a difference with his predecessors
this is someone who is prepared to take
risks to change things and I think the
best example of that is what's happening
in North Korea where everyone in the
United States was telling him don't go
and meet him in Singapore and as he
promises to give you something in return
and Trump over all that he went he took
a very big risk and now we are seeing
the first possibility of a breaking of
the deadly
in North Korea so this is someone who is
prepared to shake things up and we want
to be the people inside the tent talking
to him as his best friend
internationally but making sure that
we're working together to devalue defend
the values we both agree had a 90 minute
conversation with just the interpreters
with Putin didn't he during the Helsinki
summit I mean what was happening at the
Foreign Office when that was going on
you must have all been biting your
fingernails wondering what on earth they
might have been talking about well okay
I'm gonna have to disappear the moment
to go off to the Security Council but um
you know look at what he was doing that
his view about Putin and he said this to
me when I met him when he came to the UK
is that this is a man with his finger on
the nuclear button one of the big
nuclear powers and America has a
responsibility to have a relationship
with him a dialogue with him to make
sure that we minimize the possibility of
unintended accidental conflict and so he
feels he has a responsibility to do that
and that's why he was prepared to take
that risk and you know he got quite a
lot of flack for some of the things that
happened in the press conference
afterwards but this is a man who is
prepared to take risks and Britain needs
to be the trusted voice inside the tent
talking to him as his best friend
internationally and helping him succeed
I know we've got another few minutes as
agreed with you so let me move on to
brexit if I may the checkers deal is
dead finished done now is the time to
consider alternatives what's what's your
alternative I don't agree with that and
I think now is the time for a change
from the European Union we cannot have a
situation in a negotiation between a
sovereign power library one of the
biggest countries in the EU and the EU
where every time we come up with a
proposal instead of engaging with that
proposal they simply say I'm sorry that
doesn't work come back with something
else
negotiations require two parties to
engage seriously
hasn't been happening and you know
Britain is not going to keep coming back
with more we have put on the table some
practical proposals which mean that we
can honor the spirit and letter of the
referendum and reassure businesses that
they can have the frictionless trade
that they want their sensible proposals
we now need some engagement from the EU
okay but but that's not in the form of
checkers is it because the European
leaders have rejected it a lot of your
back benches have rejected it the Labour
Party have said that they won't vote for
it if it comes if it and when it comes
to the House of Commons checkers is dead
it needs to be something else what's the
alternative well we are prepared to have
a proper discussion I would simply say
that at this stage in the negotiations
it was always going to be like this
there was always going to be a moment
where everyone was looking into the
abyss but now what we need is calm heads
to prevail we need people to look at the
very practical proposals that the Prime
Minister has put on the table and I
think when they look at them they will
realize that actually this is a very
sensible way to deal with all the
different tensions all the different
trade offs they did look at them and
Thank You Milly ated her when she went
to Europe last week well I think that
she stood up for Britain and what she
did was she made it clear that she has a
bottom line and they needed to hear that
and I don't think they treated her with
respect and I think they can see now
that they have a someone who has deep
principles always treats people with the
greatest of courtesy but never mistake
British politeness for British weakness
we're the kind of country when our backs
against the wall we fight back and from
the European point of view if we ended
up with a messy divorce with huge
acrimony it would take a generation to
put right and I think that would be a
real tragedy for the whole of Europe so
I think they have a responsibility now
to sit down and engage properly so do
you think that cheque has this still has
some hope of being passed or do you
think we need to move more towards the
Canada do well I think it's the basis of
an agreement and we are very confident
that in the end
Karm heads will prevail and we can get
an agreement we we've never said that
we're not prepared to negotiate on
individual elements but what we have
said is that we will never sign up to
something that is not consistent with a
letter and spirit of what the British
people voted for we are one of the
oldest democracies in Europe and that is
the thing we have to respect first and
foremost we have heard from the Prime
Minister that no deal is better than a
bad deal you've previously said that we
would regret that for generations if
it's not checkers
could we be finding ourselves in a
position where we do live without I will
answer that but then I'm going to have
to be on my way I'm afraid let's be
clear because we would never sign up to
something that is not consistent with
what the British people voted for then
of course it is possible that we don't
end up with a deal and we hope that
doesn't happen I've always said that if
we don't end up with a deal Britain
would find a way to prosper and flourish
we've had you know this is a challenge
but we've had far bigger challenges in
our history before and this is a country
that that knows how to fight its way out
of difficult situations and that is what
we would do but for the continent of
Europe let's not forget that since 1945
we have all prospered we've all become
richer than ever before in our history
because we've had peace because we've
had a system where large countries
haven't been walking into small
countries and Britain and its
continental partners have been working
together so let's not put that under
threat by a huge messy ugly horrible
divorce that's wholly avoidable this is
a moment to sit around the table and
come to a sensible deal that works for
Britain and works for the EU I know
you've got to go I'm going to ask you
this I know you know if I ask you about
whether you want to be lead or not you
won't tell me so what I'm going to ask
you instead I'm gonna put it a different
way we have got a campaign at Sky at the
McCormick debates happen we want
political leaders to have to face up to
each other ahead of any general election
campaign as you know it's not written in
law at the moment we are trying to press
for that what do you think well we have
a leader with treasom a and I
the way that she engages ahead of
elections is obviously a matter for her
but I just want to make this point if I
may don't underestimate resume I think
what's happening at the moment is that
you know after that very difficult
general election maybe some people in
Britain didn't appreciate the steel at
the heart of that lady and we are led by
someone very tough and very resilient
and I think now people in Europe are
beginning to realize the same and I
think that underestimated underestimated
resume is one of the biggest mistakes
that anyone can make right now and I'm
talking about steely ladies if you
apologize to your wife yet forgetting
her nationality wrong you know I am
blessed not just to have a beautiful
lovely wife but also someone with a
great sense of humor and when I got her
nationality wrong I was incredibly
nervous I picked up the phone to
apologize to her and the first word she
said to me was konnichiwa which is hello
in Japanese so so she has a great
Chinese sense of humor but sushi is
banned from the household for a while
thank you